uh we've got a table here that's what
spreadsheets do um they're called
spreadsheets because
they're modelled after the program is
more than after
accountants and people like that who
would literally get an enormous piece of
paper a big sheet of paper and spread it
out on their table because they need to
see hundreds of numbers all at once
hence why it's called a spread
sheet okay now if you look
at the bottom of page 62. you can see
there's a table there okay and uh it
says copy complete this table now you
could do it by hand or
you could enlist this to help you okay
so here's what we're going to do
to start with uh let's do a bit of
formatting before we put any data in
this so we all have something consistent
so you notice that the table they've got
has uh three rows three rows and it's
got let's see one two three thirteen
columns okay so what i want you to do is
using your cursor have a look at um the
screen have a look at this my screen i
mean everywhere screen you can see i've
got my cursor there and i'm going to
drag out
in fact just an extra row you'll see why
shortly so i'm going to do four rows
like that you can see i'm holding down
and i'm going to go all the way across
until i've got
13
columns okay
so you can see i've got them all
highlighted 4 rows and 13 columns
columns columns
vertical things okay all right so now up
in the top your screen might look like
this
you might not be able to see all of
those menus that ribbon up the top okay
so if you can't i want you to double
click on home and you'll see all these
options come up
in particular i want you to have a look
near the top left
underneath where you've got your font
your font size colors all that kind of
thing write this in there in the middle
you'll see there's um a bunch of grid
lines okay i want you to open that up as
a menu
and it'll give you a whole bunch of
options for borders that you can place
in there okay so all we're doing is like
this is the equivalent of you getting
out your ruler and drawing a bunch of
lines if you highlighted that number of
cells i want you to hit all borders and
you should get that
can you see that raise your hand if you
can see that you've got your borders
there hands up straight hands up
straight
okay
so now i'm going to fill in
some of the information here when you
look at the table it says a number x i'm
just going to put x
right just type in x there
and then it says on the next row a
number squared
so i'm just going to write x
squared
on the next row they've got x cubed
we're just going to leave that fourth
row for a second
all right now then across the top across
the top you can see they've got the
numbers 1 to 12. now you could type in
the numbers 1 2 3 4 5. if you were
writing this out you'd have no choice
but
where in excel this thing is a giant
calculator we're going to get it to do
the numbers for us okay no
you do need to do the first number one
so you type that in
so i know pretty pretty
groundbreaking stuff right but now we're
going to get the calculator excel to do
the rest for us so
stop um stop entering things on your
spreadsheet for a second and look up so
that you don't miss this critical step
i've been saying i've been referring to
this as a calculator every one of these
little boxes they're called cells can do
a calculation for us right so in order
to get it to do the calculations for us
i start by saying don't do this follow
with me first i'm going to type in
equals and that's a signal to excel to
not just type out whatever i've got
but to calculate
once i put an equals my cursor is still
there i'm going to take my mouse and i'm
going to click on my cell which has the
number one in it
you've got some squiggly lines probably
your um your squiggly lines will look
better than mine because i've got an old
version of excel
but then what's happened here what does
this mean right it means b1
excuse me
this is a coordinate system right so b
means the columns and one means the rows
and it's helpfully put it in color for
you so it says this doesn't just mean
like b1
the words it means a cell
okay now what i wanted to do is add one
on so i'm going to say plus
one okay you can type that with me
equals
put in your equals
click on the cell you want or
alternatively you can just type v1
and then say plus one have you got it
yeah
okay now when you when you hit enter
boom mind blowing okay admittedly
it's two that's not that interesting
okay
here's where it starts to get
interesting see this cell
if you double click on it it'll bring
the formula back okay just so you can
see it
what it means is not just b1
and then add a number
what it means is just look at the cell
one to your left that's what b1 is see
this is one to the left just look at
that cell and add one that's all that
means
so now if i press escape it will go back
to being a two
if you are highlighting that cell and
press copy
ctrl c for copy and you see you've got
the squiggly lines happening again
now i want you to go and select
highlight all of the cells to the right
you can see they're all highlighted
there okay now i just copied this cell
ctrl c
so now i'm going to paste it into all of
those cells control b
control v for paste
okay now
you can see
it's added on one every single time
to go from this row the first row
to the next row x squared
what would you do now you can mentally
because these are fairly small numbers
you can calculate all these numbers but
if they were bigger
you would need a calculator so you'd
punch them in one by one into your
calculator and then you would write them
in okay
but we can get excel to do this for us
okay so here right beneath the one i'm
going to start a new equation and this
time i'm going to write it up for you so
you can see what i'm doing okay
my calculation is going to go equals
now i want to square the cell right
above so i'm going to click on that cell
again it's b1 so i write b
now if you look on your calculator uh
sorry if you look on your keyboard
there's no button unlike your calculator
which just says
square or q for that matter or anything
else so excel uses a code one of your
keys to indicate a power it uses this
button
it should be above the six it's called a
hat literally it's called a hat okay so
if you type in shift six you'll get this
character
so this means b1 whatever number is
there
to the power of now i want to square it
so that's the power of
2.
so type that in
and then enter and then hit enter and it
will calculate now unsurprisingly
unsurprisingly one squared is one
if you were doing this on paper you'd
have to repeat that again for two
and three
now the whole point of excel we've been
saying is it can do calculations for us
and it can do them all in one fell swoop
unlike you and your slow hand calculator
so i'm going to take that formula
all it means is look at the cell above
you
and square it i'm going to take all the
cells to the right
and i'm going to paste
and it does them all at once
have a look at the next row
again i want that top number there b1
but i want to cube it right so what
should i type in you press c
press you type in the equals b1
so let me just write b1 and then you
press
shift c
what's that called again what's it
called um a hat then you type three then
you press enter and you get one
okay but then if you click
ctrl c on that
and then highlight the rest of the boxes
up to end and press ctrl v
you get the answers q bam
thank you very much ethan well done in
case you didn't catch that
we went through the same process
instead of a two we had a three that's
the only difference between
squaring
and cubing